hey everyone today we're talking about
how to use photoshop's AI generative
fill to make parallaxing jobs easier
like you see in this example let's get
[Music]
started hey everyone my name is cam with
motion science if you're new to the
channel welcome today we're talking
about how we can use AI in Photoshop to
use generative fill to make parallaxing
Easier by that I mean filling in
background and expanding edges what used
to be a very tedious process is now very
easy thanks in part to AI so before we
get started today I want to invite you
to download my free pdf guide it's my
complete guide to mastering organic
motion design if you like the motion
design that you see me create here on
the YouTube channel and you want to
create renders that are less digital and
more tactile and organic I highly
encourage you to go check it out it's
motion science. tvguide it's absolutely
free you won't regret it now let's dive
in and let's check out photoshop's AI
generative fil I do want to mention that
this only works in Photoshop 2024 or
newer the first step is to select our
lasso tool and I will speed up this
process but essentially you just want to
go around your subject in the photo like
we see here I'm going around this little
boy and I'm also making sure to include
the shadow on the ground and with him
selected it doesn't need to be perfect
we're just going to click generative
fill generate and Photoshop spits out
three different variations of what the
photo would look like like without the
boy in the image and so I go back and
forth and look at all three variations
and look at the subtle differences so
why I really like version one with the
post in the center of the fence next I'm
going to select the crop tool and I'm
going to expand the edges left and right
to make this a horizontal image for HD
video purposes and once it's expanded
all I have to do is Click generate again
and it's going to expand the image of
the photograph and again it spits out
three different variations and I'm
paying close attention to the details on
the sides to see what works and what
doesn't if one doesn't work I can
generate this again and get completely
new variations but I do like this
version here so I'm going to go with
that I'm going to duplicate the bottom
layer drag it to the top and I'm going
to rename it
boy and for this next step there's a few
ways you can do this I'm going to go old
school I'm going to select the pin tool
and with the pin tool I'm going to zoom
in and draw a mask around the boy this
for me is an old school method that just
gets the best results possible yes it
takes a few minutes to do this but at
the end of it it looks really good I'm
also going to pay a close attention to
the path of the Shadow and make sure to
include that as well once I've gone
around the entire boy and his shadow
with the pin tool I'm going to close the
path and I'm going to rename that work
path boy click okay and then I'm going
to make a selection I always like to do
a very small feather radius so we'll do
a radius of one and then you can see
here I've got four layers one layer is
the
boy one layer is the original image one
layer is the painted in foreground and
one layer is the expanded edges I'm
going to select all three of the bottom
layers and I am going to merge them into
one layer so that we have the boy layer
and we have a single background layer
with that done I'm going to jump over
into After Effects I'm going to import
as a composition retain layer sizes I'm
going to double click to open up that
pre-m I'm going to select both layers
here and I'm going to copy and paste
them into an HD comp that I have set up
here this is an HD1 1920 x 1080 you can
see that the photograph is very large so
I need to position the boy in the
background layers roughly in the frame
I'll tick the 3D box and next I'm going
to add a new new 3D camera 35 mm is just
fine I'll click okay now I'm going to
change views to two views and for the
left view I find that it's easier to
work with a top view for large images
like this switch to the top view and I'm
going to take the background layer and
I'm going to push it way back in zspace
to create some separation from the
background to the foreground next I'll
select the camera and I'm going to pull
it back on zspace as well so I can frame
up the boy with the background fence
back to one View I'm going to select my
camera tool by hitting the c key and I'm
going to move around the composition and
find a decent framing I'm also going to
hit C again to Dolly out to zoom out of
the
composition hit C again to pan around
till I get something I like I'm going to
set a key frame for the starting
position go to the end of my timeline
set another key frame and do a simple
push in with the camera to create some
Parallax I'm going to scale up up the
background image and I want to make sure
that the background image is filling the
frame and I'm going to reposition the
background image scale it up a little
larger move it up a little bit in the
frame at this point I'm going to jump
back into Photoshop and I'm just looking
here to see the original composition of
where the boy sat in the frame I don't
want to get too far away from this in
After Effects so I'm referencing his
height in the image and the composition
is not exactly how it was in Photoshop
it's close enough and I'll scroll
through my time line here and see if I'm
getting some good Parallax fine-tuning
the camera position just kind of looking
to see what is available to create the
most Parallax in this shot again
scrolling through the timeline looking
at The Parallax it's it's very subtle at
this point and previewing it just to
take a look again and noticing it's a
little too subtle for me so I'm probably
going to have to push back that
background image so I'm going to do just
that I'm going to take the background
image and pull it back in zspace by a
very large number and I'm also going to
scale it back up to fit into the
frame now that the background image is
separated further from the foreground
image The Parallax is going to be a
little bit more extreme I also am
noticing that I may get more Parallax
going left to right versus pushing in on
the image and you can see here it's
exactly what's happening so this is me
just playing around with the camera to
get the best possible move does it need
to be a push in does it need to be a pan
across the image and this is getting
more parallela
now I'm going to try adding a second
camera to experiment with a second
camera move and for this test I'm going
to change from one node to two node
camera click okay for those of you who
follow my YouTube tutorials you'll
notice that the majority of the time I'm
using a one node camera because it's a
much simpler camera to use I can get
more of the the looks I'm going for but
for this I wanted to try a camera that
rotated around the boy so a two- node
camera creates a point of Interest like
we can see here you can see that the
point of interest is on the image on the
left side the camera is pulled back and
it creates a line from the point back to
the camera and I'm going to push my
camera back in zspace once I get further
enough back I'm going to set a key frame
and then I'm also going to adjust the
EXP position so now at this point you
can see that the camera is starting to
move around the boy it just creates a
little bit of rotation around the boy
because we are using a point of Interest
go to the end my timeline and move the
camera to the other side and it's a very
subtle rotation but for an example like
this it works very well I'm also pushing
in the camera a little bit again kind of
fine-tuning where that camera needs to
be the little box we can see here is
actually the first camera and previewing
this and for a nice detail we can turn
on depth of field and because this
camera is so far back in zspace we have
to really crank up that aperture and if
I switch to two views here you're going
to see the focus distance has to go very
far forward in zspace to hit the image
of the boy because our Focus distance is
so long we also have to crank up our
aperture extremely high to get any type
of depth of field here so I'm
experimenting with the values to find a
value that
works going back to one
view turning off and on to see the depth
it's very subtle finding the need to
crank up the aperture even more to
around 1,000 pixels and then at this
point I'm going to increase the blur
level to 200% just to see it happening
it's a little bit too much at this point
so we'll reduce it back down about 150%
let's actually drop it to
125% and we'll change the preset from
Fast rectangle to heptagon this just
creates a little bit nicer blur and the
preview is looking really nice at this
point we could call the animation good
at this point or we could also finish it
with an adjustment layer and to that
adjustment layer we're going to and
apply a Sapphire effect a lighting
effect called light leaks and I found
that in the light leaks if I load the
presets here I like this one here at the
bottom called soft blue I'm going to
click load and it creates just a really
nice subtle flicker like we would see in
a documentary it looks awesome I really
dig this and we're going to call it good
so you can see here it's a pretty
awesome parallx shot it was really easy
to set up in Photoshop and then animate
and after effects I hope that you
enjoyed this lesson
as always thank you for tuning in I want
to invite you to download my free pdf
guide over at motion science. tvguide
it's going to help your renders look
more organic and less digital as always
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video